this is jonathan ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the royal
armouries museum in the uk
which houses a collection of thousands
of iconic weapons from throughout
history for this week's episode as we've
had a bunch of requests for it
he's going to be taking a look at the
ludicrous weapons of valve's classic
shooter
team fortress 2. we've got a magnum
style revolver
i happen to have freeze frame right at
the point where i can see that there's
no bore in the barrel it has no
way for the bullet to get out if there
are any other games guns and mechanics
that you guys want to see jonathan break
down let us know in the comment section
below
make sure to subscribe for more videos
like this one and if you'd like to help
out the royal
muse museum and continue to support
jonathan's work check out the links in
the description of this video
right over to jonathan
what a weird gun it's got obvious
thompson sub machine gun heritage but
it's absolutely massive
and it's got the sort of um almost
aircraft cannon ammo
drum on it very odd it's clearly adapted
from the thompson
receiver kind of scaled up stretched and
altered and then the rate of fire is
really slow
and kind of plodding it's obviously it's
meant to be this kind of big heavy
powerful gun so the thompson's a very
strange basis for it
somehow it kind of works with with the
aesthetic of it
this gun seems to work on warner
brothers
logic you open it up it's a like a
double-barreled m79
inspired grenade launcher obviously you
open it up
you dump in three rounds there are two
barrels
three rounds i'm not good at math that's
why i got into uh
museum curatorship but even i know that
that doesn't quite add up and then they
don't kind of sit there in the chambers
they just disappear so it is
it is like cartoon logic open it up put
in three rounds close it up you get to
fire three rounds
looking at the 3d model the grenade
tangent sight has sort of made it onto
this model in a really hyper stylized
way with just sort of spikes sticking
out from the inside of the
the sight frame but hey we're dealing
with essentially a cartoon
cartoon graphics here so i can't uh
expect too much the gun is modeled with
a
top lever latch thing like the m79 and a
few other guns have but the character
doesn't operate it that's just sort of
their decoration and he just breaks it
open with
sheer brute force i suppose
wow this is a very strange game i saw
the name i saw what the
what the weapon was supposed to be so
it's a german
first second world war second world war
i think uh steel
steelhead granata a stylized version of
a stick grenade so you would
ignite it um originally by pulling a
cord
and you'd throw it and it's even called
the olive pool caber
now i gathered that the the character
class is meant to be a scotsman
there's obviously a connection to the to
the character in some way but the word
caber
implies for wanting a better word
tossing and
a stick grenade is tossed but not this
one
this one you hit people with it and it
blows up and somehow doesn't frag you
only frags them and then you have a sort
of jagged headed
club you can keep hitting people with
none of this will be new
uh to those of you who played team
fortress 2 but it was new to me
not how grenades generally work it has
to be said
i'm starting to think that i'm being
trolled because the uh
the mechanics of that weapon have warped
my fragile little mind
so we've got uh on the face of it a
combination of a side-by-side
double barrel shotgun with the back half
of a lever action which already poses
some serious
implications as to how the heck that
thing's supposed to work and
then the lever doesn't cycle the weapon
the lever stays put except for loading
and operating the lever somehow
magically puts
ammunition into the gun and then you can
fire
i i've kind of lost count as to how many
shots you could fire without having to
operate the lever
don't have to insert any ammunition you
certainly don't break it open and so
another weapon with only two with two
barrels but multiple shots i don't know
what the hell's going on there
quite frankly but it uh looks like fun
i absolutely hate this word in this
context but there's a lot to unpack here
we've got a on the face of it a sort of
afghan style gizelle sort of middle east
north africa region
musket looking thing weren't really
bolt-action breech loading versions of
those
i've not seen a bolt action gizelle
i'm not sure bolt action is the right uh
phrase to use here because
there's a bolt handle but it's just kind
of going up and down and there's no mags
no feed device there's no way
to get ammunition into a chamber there's
no
up back forward down bolt cycling but
it's equally not a straight pull either
and yes i am overthinking this
and then there's the sight which looks a
bit like
a galilean optical sight which you'll
have seen if you play battlefield 1
where it's just a little pane of glass
effectively a lens a single lens
and it gives you a sort of basic optical
sight but this one behaves very much
like a telescopic site a full-on
telescoping site when you
when you're actually in the aim what a
strange gun
i was going to say this is quite a
conventional looking submachine gun
machine pistol but no there's nothing
conventional about this game at all it
does
bring to mind the french map 49
that i'm getting slight vibes of the
mauser schneller foyer as well
it's quite a plausible looking design
compared to the things we've seen so far
you know you could make a gun that
looked well amusingly you could probably
make a gun that looked exactly like that
it's firing from a closed bolt so i
can't quite believe i'm analyzing this
to this degree but um
yeah and we as we've seen you can you
can fire you can get submachine guns
that fire from the closed bolt position
it's got a cocking handle on the left
hand side so ergonomics are perhaps a
consideration in this
universe despite people having sort of
dinner plate size hands i don't know
yeah i'm not sure there's enough space
in the receiver for it to function as a
real gun
and i'm not going to encourage anyone to
go and try and make one by any means
it's quite it's fun to try and fit
things that are completely fictional to
the real world it's kind of what we do
on this series
i'm getting real quake flash quake 2
vibes from that
rocket launcher but it has got this
pseudo rpg 7
model that that makes it look somewhat
realistic
this kind of feels silly commenting on
the on the realism of these things but
um
the character kind of wafts at the
muzzle
to load several rocket warheads and they
all can be they can just be fired and
see
in series from there so again no no feed
device no magazine
no means of loading and you you all know
this already of course but um recoilless
weapons and rocket launches are
with the exception of the um things like
the m202 where you have multiple
tubes they are single shot you know you
load a single round in you fire the
single round because of how they work
of course the least perhaps the release
realistic aspect of rocket type weapons
in less realistic games like this is the
the
infamous rocket jump where you shoot the
rocket
into the ground and create a sort of
pseudo-physics effect where you are
you are propelled upwards so it's like
again it's like a bug's bunny level
understanding of physics
that um you can exploit you know
something that's not taking place in the
real world
so uh it probably doesn't take uh an
expert
to tell you what would happen if you
tried to do that in real life
it would not end well as well as the
fragmentation that
most warheads would produce the blast
damage alone is is
significant a pressure wave that exceeds
your body body's ability to take it your
tissues elastic
limit um and if you did do survive a
blast of firing rocket into the ground
you'd probably suffer life-changing
injuries but again you don't need me to
tell you this
we've got a flamethrower the flame
effect is pretty rudimentary because of
the
graphics era and aesthetic that we're
looking at so it's not
like super realistic horrific um the
actual basic design of the nozzle with
igniter and the
the actual jet of fuel is somewhat
plausible the big glaring difference is
that this does seem to use some sort of
gas
which is actually consistent with how
it's shown how the flame is shown
and we see at one point an alternative
fire mode that is just the gas without
the igniter
and that redirects her an incoming
rocket which is
which is quite fun we also we saw with
the flamethrower
class uh switching to a secondary weapon
which was
a form of flare pistol or signal pistol
and
it's sort of logical within the how the
game works in the the primary is a
flamethrower the secondary is a pistol
that can set people on fire now a flat
pistol
could set someone on fire but not really
in the way that we see depicted they're
not incendiary weapons they're not
weapons
they are tools for signaling for help
or for communication on the battlefield
they have been used as weapons though
the german army did did develop grenade
ammunition for some of its
signal pistols but they didn't function
like this and as far as i know they did
not develop incendiary ammunition feel
free to correct me if i'm wrong there
as usual there is some sort of real
world parallel if not
actual realism
[Music]
this one's a bit different this is
something much more realistic looking
uh and i have had to cheat and look it
up it is a
promotional weapon that cross promotes
with
deus ex human revolution and although
it's based on the um
the srm arms rotary mag
shotgun it's almost like a revolver
cylinder but it's the magazine
feeding the barrel above although it's
got that very sort of specific feed
system
the gun in this game does not use that
at all in fact it doesn't even need a
feed system because it's using the
character's special ability to roam
metal or
well sorry to create ammunition out of
metal so it is
metal uh in various ways
we've got a magnum type magnum style
revolver
i happen to have freeze frame right at
the point where i can see that there's
no bore in the barrel so it's although
it's got quite a lot of texture detail
compared to some of the other weapons in
the game
it has no way for the bullet to get out
styled after by any number of magnum
revolvers really
the animation is very fudged the
cylinder just swings out
doesn't have a release catch the hammer
doesn't even move
hammer stays put and i think it's
interesting to think that
if a team fortress 3 did come out i
think they would add that level of
detail to the animations because even
for a hyper stylized game like this
people have expectations of
things that move and look realistic i
really like the design of the revolver
like the lines and it's got the engraved
lady on the side which is a nice touch
so it looks like a bit of a labor of
love really compared to some of the
weapons in the game it's like not not to
suggest that a lot of work didn't go
into the others
but this one seems to have um required a
an extra flair shall we say
that's a bit of a left field weapon
there
the syringe gun they also needed some
sort of offensive weapon
and they themed it to that medic
character by having it
shoot instead of bullets or nails or
something it shoots
syringes uh mechanics of it are a little
bizarre
it's got sort of feed drum with visible
syringes in it but when you reload you
reload what looks like some sort of
medicine or poison or something that's
getting
shoved on the back of the gun and you
don't add more
syringes to it the closest parallel in
terms of actual weapons would be some
sort of flechette firing
weapon now i suppose there's a parallel
of sorts and the damage effect of this
as you can see from the numbers coming
off people
is very low which is what you'd expect
shooting lightweight
spikes at people various countries have
tried flechettes as an offensive weapon
propelled usually at very high velocity
to compensate for their very low mass
and the closest we therefore see that
sort of has worked and has been deployed
are the soviet now russian underwater
weapons that fire effectively flechettes
out of cartridge cases
something very different as a video game
[Applause]
weapon
i am familiar with the minigun gatling
gun from the
team fortress games this is obviously a
sort of a variant of it
that's a throwback to the gatling gun
1860 richard gatling's 1862 design
very similar in fact to the model one
that's on the table behind me
a couple of things right out the gate i
think for the steam punkiness of it it's
got the
front sight support um bracket and the
front sight sticking up
but there's no way to use it as a sight
in fact the rest of the gun blocks it
from users aside
the other thing that stuck out for me
was the feed device
the drum on this is underneath the gun
this uh broadwell drum as it's called
for for this type of gatling gun
has to sit on top of the of the gun it's
gravity fed
with a bit of uh mass assist from the
followers that are quite heavy and sit
on top of the stack of cartridges so all
of which over
over analysis leads me to the
interesting conclusion that this
this is very highly reminiscent of an
actual gatling gun and yet
all at the same time very different
[Music]
i think well well put it this way it's
the closest one i've seen
to a real world weapon and that real
world weapon is
behind me it's the m202 flash
uh which is actually a flamethrower
believe it or not it's a rocket launcher
that's a flamethrower
but we can tell that this is based
directly on the flash
from some of the design cues so there's
a sort of hasp
on top of it which on the real thing
behind me is used to keep the front
panel locked in place and you flick the
catch drop down the front and exposes
the
um the four rockets and there are a
couple of other features as well as the
general configuration that are taken
from the m202
which if you've seen it anywhere you've
seen it in the 1985
classic commando starring arnold
schwarzenegger
the the handle the grip is different
there's all sorts of differences the key
difference being that it has only
one launch tube even though it fires
multiple shots so this is a real theme
of team fortress 2
is that one chamber can fire multiple
shots or in this case one launch tube
can fire multiple shots
and given that it's based on a
four-barreled weapon
i don't know why it didn't just model it
with four
barrels both of the rocket-esque weapons
in this game
do call to mind the original the first
two quake games
as to how they depict a rocket weapon
very slow firing
so high damage if it hits you and splash
damage if it doesn't but you can avoid
it you can jump over it you can strafe
to the side you can
duck behind cover you've got time to
avoid it as it comes in which with real
world rocket weapons and
rocket assisted recoilless weapons isn't
really a thing
i think people people try if they see a
launch signature from the ground they'll
they'll try and
move from where they are but actual
dodging of things that are traveling a
lot faster than
what we see here is very hard to pull
off
but that's the whole point you know it's
a it's a balanced thing you get the
smoke trail so you see where it's
coming from and where it's going to and
you get the chance to
move out of the way
if you would like to support the royal
armories
well you can come and visit us
imminently uh here at leeds and also
down at fort nelson
hopefully in the not too distant future
at the tower of london as well
but some of the things we've spoken
about today you'll be able to see
on display which is marvellous we're
very much looking forward to that
you can also if you follow the links in
the description think about supporting
us
remotely doing what we do both here and
in the real world
but mainly we just thank you for
watching and see you again
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you